hello everyone thank you so much for
joining us today my name is mallory
benedict i'm a photo editor at national
geographic
and i worked on the suffrage story tied
to the anniversary of the
the centennial anniversary of the
suffrage movement that can be seen in
the august issue of national geographic
magazine
um i'm joined today to talk with these
amazing panelists about
why recruitment in 2020 is still
necessary
for to get more women involved in
politics and also the importance of
having women
included at the table when we're talking
about politics so
i'd like to start by introducing
everyone first we have
congresswoman brenda lawrence
representing
michigan's 14th district and she's also
the chair of the congressional caucus
for women's issues
um ariel hill davis is the policy
director
and a co-founder of republican women for
progress
and finally christabel cruz is the
director of new leadership
training at the center for american
women and politics at rutgers
um so thank you all for being here with
us today this is actually a very
exciting day to be having this
conversation
um with some recent news um i would love
it if
we could start by everyone introducing
yourselves
saying a little bit more about the work
that you do and maybe how you got
involved in politics um congresswoman do
you want to
kick us off
yes i would love to thank you so much
for inviting me here today this means so
much to me
um i want to just give a little snapshot
of my
journey in politics i started in
politics as a pta
mom who was very involved in the schools
and education of my children
and kept getting frustrated with that
board i said i wanted that board to do
some things they said well
it's elected i said i want to be on that
board they said well it's alexa oh my
goodness i know nothing about politics
and i was encouraged to run i ran for
school board
won by 12 votes and i want you to hear
that 12 votes so
every vote matters and i um
served eventually as a president of the
school board when my children left i
still had that yearning to make a
difference i ran for city council was
the top vote getter
the message that i want you to hear from
that is that i build the base
through the schools through the ptas and
through the moms
and so when i ran for uh city council
was the highest vote getter um served as
president
of this of the city council and then it
came a time when i wanted to run for
mayor
and what's so interesting about that
they had never been a woman
or a person of color to ever be the
mayor of the city i lived in
so i was unchartered territory
and i ran it was a hard race but i beat
a 27
year white male incumbent and so
what's significant about that do not
define yourself
limit yourself by your ethnicity by
all those things that people like to put
labels on and mayors you're not partisan
is not a republican or democrat you're
just
running for the office served 14 years
as the mayor of that city
and then ran for city council i lost the
first time i ran
so that's something i want you to know
don't think every race you're gonna win
and if you lose if you still believe in
it do a better job the next time but run
again
and i'm in my uh third term i just won
my primary and i just want to give some
bragging rights
i had a primary and i
got 93 of the vote with someone
challenging me so i believe in working
hard public service is honorable
it is not a time for you to get
notoriety
cameras and and to become a celebrity
it's a time for you
to be humble to serve and to protect the
people who put their trust in you
thank you so much thank you and
congratulations to you
also um ariel do you want to share a
little bit about what you do
absolutely um congresswoman first of all
congratulations on on winning your
primary was such an impressive number i
mean that's incredible
and i think the lessons that you just
kind of imparted
through your story are also things that
we talk about with um with republican
candidates that we work for
so um i'm ariel hill davis and um as
mallory said i am a co-founder and
director of policy for republican women
for progress
um so we came on the scene after
reforming after 2016 we were republican
women for hillary initially
um and really what we pivoted
towards was this idea that we think um
we need better representation and more
representation in the republican party
for women
um and part of what is required to do
that is building the infrastructure in
the pipeline to do it
our perspective as i said in the article
with nat geo
um is that we're about 20 years behind
where the democratic side is
um and we're building an external
structure to
support and train republican women to
run for office
um you know my background is really i
come from a moderate republican family
we talked politics around the dining
room table
i came to dc right after college um and
i love public policy
i'm a wonk i'm a nerd um and i really
just want to encourage
more women across the board but um
particularly republican women since
we're at such deficit
to really step into um leadership roles
and
run for office because you know we need
women's voices and we need republicans
women's voices
to come up with good public policy and
policy
different policy outcomes than we're
seeing right now
yeah thank you so much for that um
kristabel do you want to share a little
bit
introduce yourself sure um
so first of all thank you so much for
having me here today and um
again congratulations also to
congresswoman lawrence that is huge
um and i'm just so honored to be on a
panel with all of you
with you both i think this is going to
be really insightful
i'm happy to be here i work as the
director of the new leadership program
at the center for american women in
politics
which is a unit of the eagleton
institute of politics at rutgers
university the center or cop as we
frequently call it
is the leading source of data and
analysis on women in american politics
and we provide data and analysis but we
also
trans transform or try to implement some
of that data and analysis
into training programs and education
programs
and so i work with those programs
specifically
especially the new leadership program so
new leadership is a state-based
program that gets college women this
includes community college four-year
college
women in different states right now
we're in 22 states
and the program that i run is in new
jersey
um but we get these college women
interested in politics and running for
office
and public leadership generally and
getting political jobs
government jobs but also in advocacy and
learning more about the political
process and ways to get involved and be
leaders within that field and so we
utilize this program as a way to inspire
women within each state but also connect
them to the issues in their states
and connect them to leaders within that
state including especially
women political leaders so they get to
learn from them meet with them speak
with them
we hold a summer institute each summer
this summer unfortunately we were unable
to do so it is a residential program so
with what is currently going on we
couldn't um with the pins i think we
couldn't
have the program this year but we're
looking to come back next year and
uh stronger and maybe differently and
more creatively than ever
um and uh it's a program that's free of
charge to students so it's really an
opportunity for
women of all diverse backgrounds across
the state
including non-traditional students so
not just young women but women of all
ages
to learn more in an environment where we
have
lots of resources to give um so that's
that's what i do now um my road into
politics very briefly was literally just
um you know growing up in a household uh
with parents that were very cared a lot
about politics
just due to um you know being from
dominican republic and
dealing with uh us colonialism and
political history and
um just getting active and getting
involved and
um you know they were community
organizing when i was at a young age and
i learned a lot from them
and uh i just continued on that path
i always had a passion for it um and i'm
studying
um to get my phd in political science
now with the focus on women in politics
specifically and that's how i ended up
at cox
i'm really happy to be there doing the
work that i do
wow yeah this is an incredibly inspiring
group of
people i'm so honored to be here with
you all and learn more about what you do
even though we've chatted before
um so i'd like to get started by talking
about
some news from yesterday you know i mean
this is
happening at such a great time kamala
harris just named
the um running mate to joe biden as the
vice presidential candidate um you know
obviously i probably don't need to tell
this group but how historic it is for
a black and indian american woman to be
put in this position um so i'd like to
start with
the congresswoman if if you would kind
of share your reflections on
what this moment means and the
significance of this
this has been uh just a really uh
during the let's let's define where we
are now we are in a state
of reform cries from the street for
uh racial um awareness
to eliminate discrimination this this
reform that the streets are crying for
as a result of george floyd and then to
have
a vice president who is the nominee for
president
to nominate for the first time in the
history of this republic of this country
a woman of color to stand next to him as
the vice
president of the united states for me
being a black woman
is generational pride knowing the
journey of my people
to to be here as a black woman myself
feeling
validated saying you know yes i've had
some tremendous success in my life but
this
is just so symbolic of an
opportunity for the country to come
together that everyone needs a seat at a
table
we're all in this together um
you know the saying we may have come on
different votes but we're all in the
same house now
uh she's the daughter of immigrants and
that is a powerful statement
as well so i'm very excited i endorse
kamala harris for president
i thought it was remarkable that in that
sleazy
of candidates for president there stood
this black woman
who was qualified who had the strength
and the tenacity to stand up and say
i want to sit in a seat that has never
been held by a woman
never you know and i feel that i'm
qualified to do that and i was intrigued
by that and supported her
um if i could just give a quick
overview of what we have now in congress
there's 105 women
on the u.s house of representatives and
i'm so glad arielle is here because the
republican party has not pulled their
share of the weight
it's really sad we unfortunately we sit
on different sides
of the house floor and you look over on
the republican side it's a sea of white
men
and i think it is only like 13
republican women currently and
i know some of them personally i serve
with
in the women's caucus and we represent
all the women
in congress some tremendous women
but i can tell you they still tell me
stories of having to break through the
conversation to
have a seat at the table because it is
truly a man's world on that side of the
aisle
i'm so excited that the diversity that
came in
this year through the women the first
uh native americans the um the muslim
women the
um women who came in from different
ethnic groups most of our diversity is
it's coming from the women and that says
something about
minority women we have to fight so hard
i mean it is not
easy being a woman but you put an ethnic
label on us
and some of the cultural just sexism
that's built into our culture
uh for us to stand up and fight we're no
joke
and uh it's just just been really
exciting
there are 105 women 48 of those
are women of color which makes 46
46 of the women in congress
are women of color that's very powerful
and very it's worth noting and just
you know put on the heels of that that
we're gonna have our first
uh i know the republicans don't want her
to win but i
i say to have the first vice president
of the united states
to be a woman and to be a woman of color
is just
to me speaks volume of where we are as a
country
yeah absolutely that was so powerful and
so well put thank you so much
um it's certainly a historic moment and
makes me feel a little bit emotional
especially to hear you talk about it um
so thank you
and to kind of add on to the numbers
that you were sharing
uh from actually from cop today i got a
an email alert that we have a lot to
celebrate today
um in addition to kamala harris being
named the vp
candidate according to cox yeah
we have 183 democratic women have
secured nominations for the house
and republicans have also set a new
record with 78 gop
women running for nominations in the
house or with nominations for the
house so far so with that said women
have set a new record this year for the
for overall major party house nominees
with 261 women nominees so far
so far and that's about about 30 more
than in 2018 which was a benchmark year
for women
in congress so this is very exciting
it's very i have chills this is so
exciting right now and so
kristabel do you want to start kind of
like what is the significance of this
right now
sure i can start um i just want to first
send a shout out over to our data team
at cobb who worked so hard to get those
numbers out
today and yesterday um just to
especially to chelsea hill our
inspiration services manager and dr
kelly ditmar
one of our scholars who just did
incredible work these people stay up
on election night and count these
numbers personally and individually and
do such great work getting it out there
on time because they recognize the
importance of
of tracking and analyzing and
understanding those numbers
these records that are being set are
huge and
i think i think for us to understand and
interpret
what is currently happening in terms of
women running for office especially also
thinking about the numbers the increase
in republican women running for office
which i know i really probably
will talk about um this is it's part of
responding i think to the current moment
um and what is currently going on just
really wanting folks
in office who are willing to change the
status quo
um and do things differently but also
work within a system that they have been
participating in
as congresswoman lawrence said you know
she got involved
uh in politics you know as a pta mom and
that is the story of so many other
women who got involved in politics the
research has shown that women
often get involved because they're
interested in solving issues they're
interested in representing their
communities it's not as much about
accolades or merit although that's fine
too but that they
are interested in getting things done
and at a time
in which we need things done and we've
seen in the last
few years how um how downhill things can
go
i think women are interested in solving
some of these issues and getting
in the front and getting their hands
dirty and getting that work done
and that's i think what we're seeing i
think what we're also seeing
is the important work of organizations
um like the one i work for but also
organizations that specifically work on
recruitment um so
organizations like ariel's organization
republican women and also organizations
across the board that work
specifically to recruit women i think
especially after 2016 we saw
these organizations growing more and
really going into turbo mode on
raising funds for women on finding and
recruiting women candidates
um on supporting incumbents that they
felt you know
women women incumbents and that they
felt um you know
were supportive of women's issues and um
really just
just seeing um communities come together
around candidates like this right
um so voters uh you know folks who who
run orgs and
and support women specifically and then
also the candidates themselves that were
interested in just getting things done
um and we know women are really great at
that so
ariel what do you what do you make of
these these numbers for
for your party yeah um well
a couple things um first of all i'm very
excited about
kamala being um joe biden's vp pick
i think it is far past time that our
government
looks more like our country does um and
i'm very excited about that
um on a personal level um in terms of
the republican side and the numbers i
think
we are so excited to see as many women
kind of getting into the game
on our side this cycle um i think in no
small measure
on the republican side we've taken
inspiration from the blue wave that
happened in 2018 and how many powerful
women
on the democratic side came out and i
think they serve as both an inspiration
for i think republican women and then
also i think it spurred
republicans to say we are so excited to
see all these women
but they also don't speak necessarily to
how we would approach policy
um policy issues um so it's both
um wanting to join them and i think
taking kind of strength in
and seeing what's possible on the
democratic side um and then also
having that desire to be better
represented in our own party
um that's really kind of pushed a lot of
the numbers of course we have a lot of
different organizations that also
came out of um of 2016 quite frankly on
both sides
um that we're interested in elevating
women and investing in women
um politically a little bit more so so
um you know republican women for
progress we partner with a lot of other
organizations
um and some packs that are that have
kind of come out um
and started supporting female candidates
a little bit more uh
the one thing i would say on the
republican side
which is and not to be a downer on this
because i love seeing as many women as
we have right now in the field um
but a lot of the women that we are
actually looking at who've made it
through the primaries are not going to
win
and i don't think it's necessary to win
on your first run
so like i am a big supporter of you run
once you're gonna learn so many lessons
get ready to run again if you don't win
so i by no means think that that is a
negative
overall but i do think that something
the republican side
um is particularly prone to is uh we
set up candidates sometimes to run off a
glass
cliff um so at least in our work
at republican women for progress i can
think of two candidates off the top of
my head that initially were going to run
in far more competitive races that they
had a much better chance in
and they were encouraged um very
strongly to switch
um into fields that were going to be
more difficult for them
um and the candidates that then are are
running in these more competitive races
are kind of the hand-picked men
um from the party so i would say we have
a lot of work to do
um but i think i'm so proud of
all of the republican women who have
decided to you know use their voices
and lean into this idea that they also
deserve a voice
um and a seat at the table um and they
don't feel like they're being well
represented
where we are so um again i think we got
to build that ground swell but
um it does make me a little sad that
we're looking at these big numbers and
on our side it's still going to be a
small gain most likely but
um our our job is then to support all of
those women
on you know after the race is run um
you know one thing that we try to do
with all of our candidates that we work
with and that we're in touch with
um if they lose the race i mean if they
win give them a call and congratulate
them but you know who really needs the
call it's the women that have
have not won their race and we tried to
call and reach out
and thank them for what they did and
encourage them to like think about what
they're going to do the next round so
um yeah that's kind of where we are as
as
as we look at the numbers for this cycle
that's really helpful to know um and to
get that insight and to piggyback off of
that ariel i mean
why do you think the numbers are so much
lower for republican women what are the
challenges or
specific hurdles that more conservative
women
are facing when they're considering or
haven't even thought of running for
office
um i see a lot of it as being an issue
um
republicans are very fond of saying that
we don't play identity politics right
um i think the problem with that is that
when you look around and 90 plus percent
of the party is made up of one
particular demographics
that becomes your de facto identity um
but the problem i think
when approaching the issue then of how
to run
as a woman is how how do you kind of
lean into your experience
if you don't come from a boardroom if
you don't come from a business
background as a woman
if you are not allowed to talk about
your experiences as a woman without
being accused of playing identity
politics or
you know the woman card so to speak um
so i think
one of the challenges that we have is
really
convincing women on our side like you
are going to commit problems from a
different position
than your male counterparts and that is
a strength and that diversity
can give you such better insight into
some of the problems that we're facing
as a country i think particularly right
now where we are lacking empathetic
leadership on our side
women naturally are more attuned to that
i think um
and so i see just like a huge need for
it and
a desire for that actually on our side
um and
i think we have to figure out how to
pivot for women and convince them that
they have the skills and convince them
that they can
they can do the job um and i think that
that cuts both ways um the identity
politics is very specifically
as it relates to republicans but um
women
the first thing that women ask usually
when they are asked to run for office
and women do need to be asked to run for
office most of the time
the first thing they ask is what is this
going to do to my friends and family
for men the first thing that they ask is
can i win this race
and so i think that you got to figure
out how to how to support women
in making what they think is going to be
the best decision for themselves they
can make it confidently
and that it's not going to negatively
impact the other relationships they have
in their life that they're balancing
uh i would like to weigh in on that um
when i counsel women who are
contemplating and i'm encouraging them
run for office
there's a couple things you need to do
every
person wants to run off has to develop a
team you have to have a field director
you have to a person to raise funds
you need a campaign manager and for a
woman i said you need a dedicated
care child care person on your team
because politics is not fair it's not
easy it is you become literally
this is how crazy politics you put a
bull's-eye on your back and say come at
me
and how you handle that bullseye bull's
eye is really how you become
effective and my children i started
on politics and school board it was
fortunate because events i had to go to
were school oriented
so i was able to take my children but as
i
you know moved up in politics the
meetings and the events
i went to were not kid friendly so
it's my daughter's track meet you know
how do i juggle
going you know her saying mom you're not
there for me and me fulfilling my oath
of office
to be at a meeting so it is um
i don't like to sugarcoat anything this
is not
an easy life but is it worth it is the
rewards
of helping people being part
of you know this democracy
that we enjoy in this country is
absolutely worth it but it is not easy
i was fortunate that when i got into the
really demanding parts of
politics my children had graduated from
school
so you know at that point they don't
even want to be seen with you so
um it worked out
the other thing i wanted to mention is
the power
of why we're seeing so many women so
when i ran for office
when i did my research 60
of the voters in the 14th district in
michigan
which is 700 000 people 60 percent were
women
i want you to think about that that and
the statistic is
across the country the highest number of
voters in america
are women so if women actually put
themselves out there and relate
to other women we can win nobody wants
to take a man
out i mean i have endorsed and supported
men
but i am excited when i have opportunity
kamala harris
to have a woman sit in a seat that
normally isn't held by men
um this is the 100th year
the 100th year and august is the month
where we
as women and i hate to use this term
were
given the legal right to vote
now just like i have a story as an
african-american
being oppressed in this country there
were
decades and centuries of women being
oppressed
in the political system and so
when we talk about the games that men
play some of it is so ingrained you know
that the
term we use is unconscious bias the
unconscious bias a man will be better in
politics because you know it's the men
who were the political strength of this
country
well the reality is we were building
those men
because women historically have been the
the
foundation and the base for building an
infrastructure for a campaign for a man
and after we got the right to vote
that's when you saw the numbers of women
start to increase and and then 2016 was
just
amazing and it seems like my republicans
i had a couple of the republican women
said what do you do how did you all
do this and developing organizations
like i was supported by
emily's list emily's list is a
phenomenal
institution that raise money support
uh teach women how to win political
offices
and i and i'mma yield back with this one
statement
one of the lifelines or the mother milk
of politic is raising money what are we
taught as women you don't ask anyone for
money you don't
beg for money well donald gunn is a
politician you beg you ask you plead
you get the money because you cannot run
successfully
for an office without money
i don't like it i wish we would put a
cap
on how much money you can raise in
america because i think
it is so out of control and it just has
too much influence on our political
system but the reality
today is that you have to raise money
and for women i know culturally i was
told my grandmother taught me
you do the hard work you do the work and
you'll be recognized well that's not a
reality you gotta learn how to brag on
yourself you gotta stand in front of a
camera and say i
am the best vote for me i'm better than
anything you've ever seen
and i'm gonna change the world and this
is what i have done
and i've done this and someone told me
yesterday i was brilliant the men
do it every day but women we're just not
trained to do that
and so it's it's a new day um
you know shirley chisholm i stand on her
shoulder she was the first black woman
elected to congress
and i hope that my shoulders stay strong
i'm working on it so that i can have
generations of women stand on my
shoulders to run in the future
yeah that's it's so inspiring and i'm
also really glad that you brought up
the idea of uh getting involved
politically as a mother
because i think that's probably an
additional hurdle that a lot of people
don't think about and might not affect
men quite as much as it does women
um and you know to another point that
you said
uh christabel when when we were talking
to you for this story
you said something that i really loved
you said quote
the more government and politics
represents the makeup of the country
the more likely people will participate
and see traditional politics as an
avenue for them
can you speak a little bit more about
that and i know that a lot of your
research focuses on latino women as well
um what's the correlation there
sure um thank you for for
posing that question i think it's
important for us to think about
when we're seeing these record numbers
um this year
um one thing that it is important to
note is we're still seeing a minority
of women as candidates we're seeing an
increase in all candidates right and so
women are still in the minority of
candidates
um this year and that is the thing that
i think has been
um the most difficult in getting more
women to run for office is
it's sort of the not that you can't be
what you can't see i don't love that
statement but basically if you're not
seeing
women in office as often or you're
seeing you know the results of women
going through elections and having them
you know really just be treated and
equally throughout the election process
often what happens is you might feel as
though
i don't feel this is an effective method
for getting things done or why would i
put myself through something like that
right or things along those lines
um and so my research which is on
latinas and local office in new york
city
um i look at why how how latinas make
the decision
to run or not run for office um and it's
just something that i've been curious
about
about women and women of color generally
because we just have we have these
areas that are especially in local
office that are majority minority
um and so people often vote
co-ethnically like they will vote for
someone of their same race
but we're still seeing these really
large gender disparities within these
spaces
um and part of it is recruitment right
and so that's what we're talking about
right is
people aren't thinking of women as
candidates
or they're just and so their network of
recruitment
is not reflective of that if you're a
cisgendered
straight white male your network is
likely gonna have a lot of cisgender
straight white men in it
um and you're gonna think that that's
what a politician looks like right if
you google a politician that's often
what what people see and that's sort of
what i think a lot of organizations and
and folks in office are trying to change
now um but so
first of all the recruiters are not
doing the recruiting um part of it also
is because they just don't think women
are likely to win
um and uh or they if they do
run women um you know as ariel pointed
out earlier they'll be in seats that
they likely will not win
um you know so they'll be running as
challengers and seats that aren't likely
to
to yield um an election result that's
positive or favorable
for them um and so what ends up
happening is a lot of women who are
politically involved are active a lot of
the women that i have been interviewing
um they a lot of them say i'm not gonna
run for office because
i i feel as though either there's a lot
of corruption in my local government
you know which does happen at times um
or
i feel as though this is i don't want to
put myself through that process in order
to get elected
um when i could you know make change in
all these other avenues
and so what they're not seeing is um
they're not getting to know or see
the work of folks like congressman
lawrence often at or
a congresswoman learns or or folks in
office in in different capacities
they're not getting to know the people
who are in office
um because they feel as though they
don't represent them or they don't look
like them right and so that's why it's
so effective when you see someone like
congresswoman lawrence or you see
someone like kamala harris
um in office or running for office or in
the positions that they're in
or just as candidates because that
signals to someone else this is a
possibility for me
right this is a possible avenue for me
to get things done that i want to get
done
um or this is a possible thing that i
could win i could run and i could win
and i could make
effective change um and so i think part
of it is
is just folks either not getting
recruited um
because they're not there or folks
not running because they're not there so
if they're not seeing themselves they're
not going to have that impetus
um you know to run um and i think that's
a huge thing
um for folks across the board but i
think especially for women of color
i think one of the reasons that we're
seeing an increase in women candidates
as we've seen through cop data like
now a large portion of that increase in
women candidates is women of color
and one of the reasons for that is
because of all these wonderful firsts
that we've seen
among women of color um in office in you
know in the federal government state
government and local government
over the last um couple years but
especially on the national stage right
seeing
you know for instance kamala harris
being the first south asian woman
and the second black woman elected to
the senate right and so those
those things are exciting and they will
then motivate um
other people um who come from a
background like hamlet harris's to see
themselves as potential senators
and for the folks who are most
importantly for the folks who are
gatekeeping and recruiting for them to
see them
as potential candidates as well and
folks that that can
and should and are likely to win when
they do run
yeah i think that's a great point i mean
how
sometimes you don't know to consider
yourself for something unless you see
someone else do it first
and so this opens up a whole bunch of
possibilities for people
um ariel i'm wondering if you can kind
of talk about
what how does recruitment actually work
because
as rachel hartigan and i heard from our
reporting in the story
um multiple people said you know there
are not a bunch of
men's groups out there catered just
towards recruiting men but there are
tons of
women's groups like yours and like
congresswoman lawrence mentioned emily's
list so how does that actually
work for you yeah um
recruitment is is one of those
interesting things especially our
organization is based in
in dc and and we have some great reach
and touches and states
um but i think really what it comes down
to is what we've found
um particularly with women and i think
it it makes a lot of sense to start from
the training standpoint and you use that
as kind of your pipeline and touches for
who is interested in running and who
who's taken the initiative to figure out
what it would mean to run um so we
are partnered with the yale campaign
school and we
have done now two different republican
only
or like republican women specific
campaign training
um and we have also found that for
republican women there is
a discomfort and an assumption that they
don't belong in non-partisan spaces
um and we are trying to break down that
belief because i
it's they're nonpartisan for a reason um
but i think for republican women it can
feel like they're going to be very
exposed
um and maybe the only conservative in
the room um
so we use our training as really kind of
where our pipeline is starting
um and this year it was great um we had
we pivoted and we did it all virtually
which actually i think allowed
for a greater number of women to
participate um particularly
along like socio-economic lines right
like if you don't have to pay to come to
dc
for a weekend for this training the
virtual component
i think gave us such greater access um
and then really we rely on our different
people who have contacted us
um throughout the years um we have
different state chapters that were
active in 2016 when we were
doing some work as republican women for
hillary um you know as we've changed
and involved uh we still are very active
and in touch
um and then what you do is you just like
get your hands on them
in terms of your database and you check
in with them and you encourage them
um we have our women to watch list that
we rolled out in 2018 we have that again
this year
um and what i actually think is pretty
cool that we do is
um listen by the time that you're
running for federal office like
sure we are super supportive we'd love
to support you but actually it's women
on the state and local level
that are actually where we're way more
focused because that is our eventual
pipeline
um and i think something the
congresswoman pointed out in terms of
choosing to run
and the infrastructure that you need um
we very much are
motivated towards becoming kind of the
emily's list on the right
um which was created as a separate
structure
outside of the party structure to
support female candidates
um but part of that is giving women the
tools not just by training but the
infrastructure
in terms of who do you talk to to get a
good field organizer who can we put you
in touch with that can help with comms
um you know this is a brave new world
for a lot of candidates particularly at
the lower levels in terms of state and
local
um and really how do we encourage them
that first time and then how do we
promote them
um because i think that's the other
thing there is a very big assumption i
think in our media and what we
see which is in order to be um
a female politician you're gonna be a
democrat right like numbers are so small
on the republican side
and so part of our job is also
increasing the footprint so that women
can think oh
yeah i can run for that office and like
here's this group that's doing this
i have questions um and all four of our
founders are
pretty much on call all the time like my
phone is never by my side we give pep
talks
we get on the phone with candidates we
connect them um
with different um consultants and
different people that we think can be
helpful
we phone bank for them and that to me is
like we are so far behind
so recruitment really is like starting
with like who's out there who wants to
get in touch and then we just gotta
gotta keep our hands on up and move
forward and build from there
absolutely women helping women is so
critical
um so we have a great question from
the the folks watching this right now
and the question
is what role can voters play in
supporting the recruitment of more women
to public office
and i'll just open that up to whoever
might want to answer that
for a woman to support women it comes
down to a couple of things
volunteering for their campaigns
volunteer to be that child care support
you can get in politics you can get
called into a meeting that wasn't on
your
calendar wasn't important was i'm sorry
wasn't
even considered and it's extremely
important and you have the kids
and you know if you can't get involved
um saying running a campaign say you
know what i'm here
anytime you need to you need me to feed
them
to babysit to do whatever i need to do
and i just want to throw this this is
really a sexist comment but it's true
um i remember i was in a heated campaign
and i was running against a man
and he had children like i did but he
never
had i never saw him sloughing the kids
with him or
having the kids sit in the corner
because you know what he had a wife
and if i wanted to entertain someone or
whatever
normally it wasn't at my home because i
didn't i wasn't there to cook and
prepare the house
for the dinner the wife was there and i
looked at him one day and he
said something to me i said you know
what the only reason why you feel
confident because you got a wife taking
care of everything for you
you know if i had a wife i would be just
as confident as you are
um but the reality is is that you can
volunteer to help on a campaign
you can give money sometimes the only
thing you do i can write a check
don't think a 25 check isn't significant
if that's the best you can do
that is a tremendous help to a campaign
i have a senior citizen who every month
sends me ten dollars
she said you know i'm i'm gonna fix
income this is the best i can do
i said i am just so grateful that you
included me in your budget
and that she supports me the other thing
is
voting it is so powerful that when you
i never say vote for someone because
they are a woman or because of their
color
but when you see a woman who was
qualified
and you i've heard women say gosh she's
so good
i wish she could win well dog gonna she
could win if you voted for her and if
you got
more women to vote for her pick up your
phone and call people she is dynamic
we should vote for her and women because
we're so social
we have all of these networks that we
just don't pay attention to
if you're a soccer mom that is a base
for you to talk to the soccer moms for
them to come on board and be supportive
like for me it was the pta and i'm
talking to the other parents you know
like
i want to make a difference can you
support me you know
we we're on bowling clubs knitting clubs
reading
books uh reading uh clubs
there are so many social events your
church
where you can tell someone you know i
really believe in this
and i want to run for this support me so
women we have so many ways
and remember we're the largest voting
bloc in america
i i love that answer i think the other
thing that
i am always very clear especially when
talking to younger women
is um look around and if you i
am a firm believer and you step into
your own voice in your own power nobody
can tell your story and nobody has your
perspective quite like you do
but if you don't think you can run for
office or you are not interested in
running for office look around your
network because guaranteed
there is a woman in your network that
should be encouraged to run for office
like
give that person a call encourage them
and then
you know once they make that decision as
the congresswoman said
you know support them and that could be
taking their kids it could be
writing them a check it can come in all
different ways
but truly i think you know once they're
once they're in the race you gotta push
them into the race and then once they're
there
you gotta you gotta help help support
them um and then the other thing i just
would like to pick up on
congresswoman to your point about women
talking in our networks
um something i think on the republican
side that we are trying to combat
socially is um this sense for women that
talking about politics isn't nice
right like i don't like it's so it can
be so unpleasant i don't want to be ugly
i don't want to disagree
um but politics touches everybody's
lives right like it it is
interwoven into our day-to-day lives in
ways that we don't even begin to
comprehend
and it is okay to have opinions about
that and it is okay to talk about that
um and i think that's this other other
thing as we try to
encourage women to see politics as more
of our domain we have to get comfortable
with the fact that
there is nothing that says that being
feminine and being a woman
is not compatible with politics
um i i love both of those answers um and
i want to
expand on two points that i think were
made by both of you which i think were
great um
so the network idea is is huge right so
first telling women to run for office
right and showing
and that was part of you know answering
that earlier question about
um you know people participating because
they're seeing
um a difference i think that's a big
thing and so just making sure that we're
using our networks to celebrate to call
out things and celebrate also
um what women do once they're in office
because
women in office do make a huge
difference and this is
substantively you know represented uh
you know across the board and and
completely um
you know certified data that that women
do make a difference once they're in
office and then it doesn't matter that
they're there
um and so using our networks to share
that news right
share the wins of women show um just
what what women are actually doing once
they're in office right so looking at
the great work let's say that
congresswoman lawrence is doing and
celebrating
you know bills that she voted on that
you think are important that other
people
should know about um and showing you
know the work that she put into that
really celebrating those wins are huge
um in terms of networks too i think this
is
um one of the areas where we can learn a
lot historically from women of color
specifically
um and so thinking a lot about you know
the beauty shop politics of the 1960s
right during the civil rights era
the role that black women continue to
play in the democratic party and
recruiting
networking putting out foot traffic um
doing the work
on the ground to to really get people
talking about politics and motivated to
go out there
my mother my grandmother is about to be
90 this year and she to this day walks
herself to
the polling place and also then the day
of calls
everyone and tells them she will break
their legs if they do not
go and vote and that's as an immigrant
she really just celebrates her right to
vote
and so to her it's just so important to
get involved in so just
those networks i think we can learn so
much from women of color there because
we're celebrating this 100th anniversary
or centennial of suffrage but
for women of color these rights to vote
um didn't really
implement themselves in so many ways
until later and so and that's partially
due to these
these tighter networks um and then i'm
just calling out
um so we talked about that positive side
of celebrating the wins but also calling
out under representation
so if you're looking at a local election
right and you get a local newspaper and
you're noticing that
women candidates are not getting as much
play um in that local paper
or sometimes they're completely excluded
from stories about candidates or or
local elections
you can write a letter you can call and
they will likely start making those
changes and that's just like sort of a
small thing you could do within your
local network or community
um to make um that difference and
encourage more folks to run
and then in terms of recruitment too two
huge things you can do is first you can
support orgs that recruit women to run
so for anyone out there that wants to
support the work let's say that arrow's
doing or any of these other
organizations
um either through time or or money i
think about organizations like higher
heights that work specifically to get
black women elected
or lupe latinas united for political
empowerment organizations that do just
such great work
um specifically to recruit women of
color um and just women who are
underrepresented generally
would just be great places to start
giving your time and attention
and they could use any help they can get
usually
um even if you cannot donate financially
um
and the other place would be then your
local political party
um so i would say consider running maybe
for county committee like a local
party that's a local party office that
you can hold
as a as a citizen a resident in your
area
you don't need a lot of votes for it you
really just need a certain amount of
signatures
often these seats are you know empty
um or you know filled through
surreptitious
means uh so as we've seen in new york
city we've dealt with that
um but that's a that's also a huge thing
because then you get to help decide who
your local political party recruits
um and endorses as the candidate
in your local election and as we saw
through the congresswoman story often
through local politics and as ariel's
mentioning
that's how we end up with candidates at
these higher levels
um but yeah i mean even if we're looking
back at 2016 or 2018
a lot of the work that was done was just
from on the ground work
um and that's how a lot of these
candidates were able to win their
primaries and that's what we're seeing
again in 2020 so
put yourself out there and find ways to
support um
parties orgs and then just recruit
within your network
um i'd like to you know we're about to
run out of time here but something
you know we've been talking about
recruitment and getting to that
what seems like kind of the starting
line so you're there you made it
congresswoman lawrence what about
inclusion after you've been elected
how can how can we be better at being
more inclusive
um and incorporating the viewpoints once
people are actually elected
so i will tell you that is your
challenge once you make it through the
hurdle of being elected then it's
you're in the room where it happens and
you know it's just like
shirley chisholm said if they don't they
don't give you a seat at the table bring
a folding chair and just sit there
um pull it up and get to work
there's often and i know the republican
women must deal with this because
sometimes on committees
and other things they are the only woman
in the room
i've had republican women say they have
to struggle to be heard because they're
talking or they'll bring up a nation
we only hear that and so
there's all kind of sexism that you have
to work through on the democratic and
republican side
let me give you an example of maternal
mortality which is
a huge issue for us in the women's
caucus
in america we are the
highest nut we have the highest number
of women dying in childbirth
than any other developed country and
then to add insult to injury
the largest number within those numbers
are black women
and so when you that has never even been
on the radar on the table
and it's it's something that we
as a country should find appalling
childbirth is not something new
childbirth and and we'll see
underdeveloped countries their numbers
are
dropping and so um
i i'm going to get a little
controversial here the
the latest talk about reproductive
health is about birth control
how dare a government
talk about the ability for me to have
access to birth control when they can go
get a vasectomy whenever they want they
can go get viagra no one's talking about
that
but the fact that we can manage our
lives this is not talking about pro-life
or pro-choice
this is about me as a woman determining
the right time for me to give birth so
that i can manage my education my career
and you know what a man can get a
vasectomy say i don't want to have kids
a woman should be able to do that if she
doesn't want to have kids it's her right
and so it always seems to be a different
conversation when it's the rights of
women
and often we get into these like
dismissive moments in politics where
they don't want to hear what we have to
say
so the battle continues um and that
comes from that inner strength and that
we
you can't teach that it has to be
learned is that
that in your belly when someone say we
don't want to talk about that and you
turn around say we will talk about that
today
i am your equal i'm bringing this to the
table and i want a discussion today
um i wasn't there when i first started
you know i was kind of
you know i wasn't used to being told to
be quiet
and i was like whoa you know maybe i
should stop talking you know
because no one came to my defense and
like
um it had been mentioned we have to call
it out
and you know i have when i was in
private industry
i would be at a a meeting and
a woman would present something [ __ ]
like yeah yeah then a man would come
right around say the same thing
everybody go oh that's a great idea and
i would say excuse me
she just brought that up that's her idea
and i do think it's a great idea we
should give her credit for it
sometimes we just have to stand up for
each other and first of all stand up for
ourselves
i just would like to add to i think the
congresswoman wonderful points
um i think it's something that makes me
very sad on the republican side
that we have so few women that
they really are not able to be an
effective
voting block one way or the other um and
this is kind of like how the sausage
gets made but it means that they
are not they're not enough of them to
actually dictate some of the direction
of the party
because they just don't have the numbers
yet um and so
it does lead to um not only bad policy i
think but also
um a minimizing of women although we
also see
that women are trotted out on the
republican side to account for an answer
for
the bad behavior of our male
counterparts which i think is
utterly unacceptable um and so i think
like
this all goes into how do we amplify i
think this
you amplify other women that are in the
room we also know
that women once they are elected work
better together
women you know across the aisle once
they are in office
um they offer bipartisan legislation
bicameral legislation like they
are collaborative in a way that that i
don't think men always are
um and so i think this really to me is
like the long-term push you get more
women in office i think you will see
different outcomes across the board
because you will have different
perspectives
and you will have women encouraging
other people to also listen to the
women's voices in the room
um so yeah i think i think it starts
with having to get more women elected
before you can actually be effective
particularly on our side um because we
just
we are not big enough for them to listen
to to be frank
i i just want to um echo both of those
points i think that's
really well said that the collaborative
nature um often is what we see
more often with women in politics and
they are once they're in office and we
are seeing
these sort of discriminations and one
just small point i want to make also
about the ways in which women are not
included in these areas is due to things
like hierarchy
so if we are in seniority so if we are
getting our firsts
um now or in recent times
what ends up happening then is these
women are not getting some of the
positions or committee assignments that
they really should be getting
um and that um often they are
underutilized or
or not given the the statute that they
should be given
once they are in office and so that's
just another another layer of
of the difficulties um once in office in
terms of women and inclusion
but it's just something that women have
just continued to push through and still
make create some of the most effective
legislation that we've seen
so so i i also want to bring up a point
that
was disturbing to me and i think um
uh it was just reference that the
colleague to colleague discussion man to
a woman that was
inappropriate but when i talked to some
of my republican women
oh it's just boy talk that's just the
way they talk i don't take it seriously
oh my boy my blood was boiling and
that's just not on the republican side
you know it's like when
when donald trump said those awful
things
on um about grabbing a woman's anatomy
and the way
he was talking his wife said oh it's
just
boy talk it's just locker room talk it's
not a big deal
and the metoo movement and everything
else is happening
it has really you know put a line in the
sand this is no longer acceptable it's
not funny
it's not you're not a little boy anymore
you're a grown man
in a work environment with women and
the conversation must be respectful and
dignified if you want to talk that way
to
to your companion who's a woman or you
feel like
you want to talk away in your privacy
but it's not acceptable
and men are very nervous right now
because they
have had years and years of a culture
where it was okay to say hey baby you
know or
be quiet little girl and go home it was
acceptable that
that was our culture and now with the
pushback some of the men
are uncomfortable and then some of the
women are just saying is it's okay
you know leave them alone they're
they're you know
i i'm not offended you know and i had to
tell one woman well
i'm offended for you if you not i am
because i would never tolerate a man
talking to me like that
and so we have some work to do
internally
of teaching women their value their um
the the rights that they have to be
treated with
being treated as an equal we're not
their baby we're grown women
we um if we walked up to them and said
little boy go over here and sit down
it's like i'm a man who
you think you're talking to well i'm a
woman
i'm not your baby i'm a congresswoman i
am an adult
and i have a name so i just wanted to
bring that up
no absolutely that's a great point and i
think it brings up an
important note about the importance of
allyship as well whether it's
between men and women or democrats and
republicans i think that those
ties that you create once you get there
i would imagine
as anywhere are really critical to
you know disrupting and eradicating that
type of behavior
um i could keep talking to you
all day about this this has been such a
great conversation but
i think we do need to wrap up and so you
know i just like to
see you know we're celebrating the the
100th anniversary of the 19th amendment
obviously
you know there were some some pieces of
that that were fraught
back then and we still have more work to
do now so
i'd love for each of you to comment on
you know
what advice would you give to the people
watching this
or to women allies in general
about what do we still need to do and
how can they get involved
i'll start thank you again so much it's
so great to be on here with you ariel
and crystal
um i just i just like to use this
example and have an opportunity to talk
to women
on top of the capital of the united
states
where the the greatest form of political
power in the world
there is a statue and it's a woman she's
called lady freedom she has in her hand
a sword in one hand and a wreath of
peace in the other
whenever we talk about our democracy and
the
checks and balances the the woman is
depleted as a woman the lady of justice
where
she said justice is blind when we talk
about immigration it is that
amazing statue with brimming your poor
the statue of liberty throughout the
history of this country
women has been deplicted in those
powerful
visual marks of who we are
what we value who we are as a country
and i will say to every woman here as
ariel recruits women as um
ruckus you do your amazing work or keep
giving us the data
and keeping us informed this is
a time in history where i want every
woman 100 years we've had the right to
vote
and with their right to vote keen their
rights to be included and to be
represented
and as i talk about lady freedom on top
of the capital and
and i think about shirley chisholm being
that first one oh my gosh how lonely
that must been must have been for her
that
we lady freedom has a sword that means
that we can kick
anybody's behind we need to we can fight
and if you come after our children i
don't care if you're republican or
democrat
women stand we will stand up and fight
you for those rights and those values
but we also have the reef of peace
because we have the ability
to to to console to
reduce fear into comfort it's it's
something that is one of our powers and
i don't walk away from that our
emotional
power so i say to every woman know your
power
respect your power and do something with
it
thank you so much
thank you so much for those very
empowering words um and for being with
us today
congresswoman lawrence ariel or
christabel what would you leave with
the folks here today
i would just say to do what you can to
encourage the women in your life to see
themselves as public leaders
and and most of all too as we're doing
this work
um to get all of us more represented in
different ways
but especially for for women um as we're
doing this work
um to correct those errors of the past
and think of ways in which we can be
inclusive of all women
or women i identified folks and and
really
um work hard to to expand
how we think of who represents us um
and then finally i would say to to just
stay in the fight you know um as the
congressman said
um you know there are gonna be losses um
but losses are also wins when someone's
running
for that first time um or we're having
more you know in this case of this year
you know
we will have losses but we've got this
record number of women winning
and that's a win so celebrate celebrate
it all
and and just push for more because even
you know don't settle in even though
we've got these record numbers there's
still
so
much more work to do and um i'm excited
to
to be in this fight with all of you so
amazing this has been i could i could
talk to you guys for the rest of my day
so this has been such a
such a pleasure and such a treat um and
yeah i mean i think
get ready to be in the fight right like
we haven't been represented in terms of
of how much we make up of the population
ever
um and i think um
you know if 2016 was kind of the modern
wake-up call that we can't just leave
politics um and you know
the running of our country and the
governance of our country um
to men like which i think it was for a
lot of women i think lean into it
um find your voice
be comfortable with the fact that you
have a point of view
and you know encourage other women to
step into that space as well right i
think we get really
um nervous sometimes and i think just to
pick up on
um the congresswoman's comment about
locker locker room talk which i hate um
is i think part of the reason why women
have been trained to
to brush that off is because we are told
that we will lose our access to those
rooms
if we decide that we are uncomfortable
with the language that's being used
so ask for better um and i think
the other thing is that in terms of
finding your voice finding your place
and supporting other women
is also recognizing that we aren't
fighting i'm not fighting for myself
right like i am fighting for the women
who are coming behind me i am fighting
so that young women who are
in high school right now we'll have
different outcomes and we'll have
different opportunities moving forward
and if you can't if you can't kind of
find your voice for yourself just think
about
you know your daughters your nieces um
your friends kids that you love right
like the whole point is to just move
this forward
so that we can have better
representation that we can have a
government that is reflective of the
wonderful diversity that we have in this
country um and that's how it should be i
think we'll all get better outcomes that
way
that's such a powerful note to end on um
i could also talk to you all all day
um uh thank you all so much for joining
us
um on this kind of historic day and this
historic moment
um we really appreciate you and all of
the work that each of you are doing
so thank you everyone for coming